n'a pas obtenu la triple peut piger 2
525 tombe au jackpot
- j'ai pigé jackpot quand j'ai entendu
le mot hormones bio et danser que j'ai
fait oh my god ça tombe vers une
nouvelle pour guy j'espère pas bougé à
faire pour que ce soit couvert pas ça
coûte cher parce que peu de médecins en
ce moment off cette option
je veux comprendre pourquoi ces poignées
de mains qui ont pu toucher quant à
bouygues pour que ça bouge
4 les femmes il faut se battre pour
avoir une hormonothérapie la plus
sécuritaire possible date cette date ça
vous venez voir ici des images de la
bande-annonce de l'auto mais non la
série documentaire de véronique cloutier
c'est sa canette finalement pour essayer
de trouver de l'information sur la
périménopause elle s'attendait pas que
c'est autant d'impact ça n'a vraiment
beaucoup s'attendaient pas non plus à
trouver cette information qui montrent
que tous ces tabous finalement sur la
ménopause du jeu qui est pas très
souvent abordés qui est pas très
attrayant ça a des conséquences sur la
santé des femmes ça se ressent jusque
dans les cabinets de médecins et il ya
justement un médecin qui se spécialise
dans ces questions qui s'appelle docteur
sylvie demers c'est mon invité c'est une
des protagonistes d'ailleurs de la série
vont sort de terre demers
bonsoir vous vous êtes une pionnière en
recherche sur les hormones féminines
qu'on appelle bio identique est tous des
questions d'hormonothérapie c'est encore
un sujet extrêmement mystérieux et vous
vous dites vous dénoncez finalement le
fait que les femmes ont très peu accès à
cette information le oui on a très peu
les femmes ont accès et je dirais même
les médecins ont très peu l'axé on n'a
pas beaucoup de formations sur le rôle
des hormones féminines en garde comme
reproducteur on n'a pas beaucoup
d'informations non plus sur les
différences enquête dans ma vie donc il
ya beaucoup travaillé et beaucoup de
travers mais pourtant quand on est dans
le cabinet du médecin comme femme depuis
qu'on parle des symptômes de
périménopause de ménopause on pense
aussitôt bouffées de chaleur ce genre de
choses là et des femmes qui ont des
migraines et des femmes qui ont une
sorte de douleurs ont prescrit des
hormones mais vous vous êtes il ya des
classes d'hormones
alors celle qu'on appelle bio identiques
dont on parle à peu près jamais dans les
cabinets de médecins de moi je veux dire
le bio identique je savais pas du tout
ce que c'était pouvez-vous de façon
simple et courte nous expliquait en gros
en quoi c'est différent des hormones
qu'on se prescrire actuellement les
amants l'identique c'est ça veut dire
que c'est désormais dans la structure
chine et est pareil aux hormones que les
ovaires produisent et salue les mêmes
actions dans corps des femmes ça n'a
rien de nouveau l'hormonothérapie bio
dans ces camps ça existe depuis aussi
longtemps que l'hormonothérapie
classique ça l'a fait l'objet d'énormes
études en laboratoire c'est plus ça qui
est étudiée donc c'est vraiment de deux
on dirait que l'hormonothérapie ont
maintenant à jour tout ce qui se fait au
niveau scientifique et monde du rouge à
gilly à tous les jours j'apprends
j'apprends que tel mais en quoi sont
plus avantageuses les hormones bio
identiques sur les hormones pour nous
prescrits c'est une excellente question
en fait il faut savoir que
l'hormonothérapie quand on mélange tout
les titres dans mon graphique yoyo en
départs commencent avant l'âge de 60 ans
ou à moins de 10 ans de la ménopause
dans les études contrôlées une
diminution non qualité totale qui varie
entre 30 et 39 pour ça dans la fameuse
étude doit il leur fait peur à des
chaises cannées terre et 26 missions nos
qualités de 31% donc énormément date
davantage à prendre de l'homme graphique
mais on fait peur à cause des risques
car votre toujours le mot risque à la
burj les risques les restes les risques
on part toujours d'euripide au risque
est jamais bien fait alors que les
bienfaits sont très nombreux alors
l'hormonothérapie duo dansé pour faire
un sort très court en fait c'est parce
qu'on a pas les risques devant nos
thérapies classiques parce que dans les
risques parce qu'on perd de trois ris
quand on parle de l'homme une api si le
risque de cancer du sein le risque
qu'elle capture et le risque de caillot
on sait que les estrogènes euros à
montreux risque de caillot mais la 72
mais graxi progestérone qui la
principale projet stienne que pour d
autres
mancunienne l'utilisent en monothérapie
elle c'est jackpot c'est à dire qu'alain
manque énormément le risque de caillot
russe que les estrogènes favorable
c'est la substance qui était responsable
du cancer du sein dans les études pour
les ex projet voit la progestérone et
qui était aussi responsable des à
capuche alors moi ce que je veux c'est
une hormonothérapie la plus sécuritaire
possible
en plus quand on perdait ce cas-ci paix
parce que les hormones cation perles
sont produits nets vont évaluer
c'est aussi ce que c'est tous efficaces
faut savoir qu'avec une monothérapie
biotique parce qu'on peut la doser et
non pas l'homme avocats l'application on
peut avoir un côté d'augmenter de
beaucoup d'efficacité et donc sa défaite
très différent on va parler de la
progestérone va avoir un effet sur le
sommeil les 10 nuls anxiété ce que n'est
pas là mais c'est très convaincant quand
vous entend alors on this une femme on
lui présente ses options là bas on se
doute bien qu'elle va aller vers vers ce
qui est mieux pour elle et si ce qui est
bio identique et mieux pour elle avant
de demander ceci dit ce n'est pas
remboursés par la ramq eu contrairement
aux autres hormones
il ya même une pétition je pense que
vous êtes impliqué dans la circulation
de cette pétition pour qu'on la joute
dans les traitements qui sont remboursés
semble-t-il que les bio identique pour
homme sont remboursés mais pour ceux
pour femmes comment vous expliquez sur
vous mais c'est parce que les hommes ont
d'abord les deux choses d'abord la
question suivante est construit comme
une hormone qui est important donc on
veut pas la modifier chimiquement on
veut les garder quelques elle parce
qu'on dit non non il faut quand même pas
le modifier très important et on
reconnaît les robes et la testostérone
en dehors et me va pas du cas on est
juste à passer à la force musculaire
la libido l'énergie tandis que les
femmes on n'a pas les mépriser on est
dans un contexte que j'appelle de
misogynie hormonal
on les méprise on pense que les hommes
et minières j'espère juste pour la
reproduction web réel
à quelques nuances près il ya takano
donc ça fait pas ici des tabous il se
fait partie justement le 2 sept
en fait une sorte d'injustice finalement
dont sont victimes les femmes parce
qu'on parle pas ça si de s'esquiver
réductrice et du d'ailleurs on parle pas
assez de la ménopause parce qu'on en
parle pas bien on n'accorde pas assez
d'attention l'inconnue reste avec des
secret puis on reste avec une
méconnaissance qui va jusque dans le
cabinet médical assez calmement s'il ya
vraiment mépris les hormones qui n'ont
pas ce que des hommes qui sont là pour
faire du tour puis donner le cancer
alors que c'est les hormones qui ont
énormément de fonctionnement correct
c'est les femmes vivent plus longtemps
que les autres à cause de leur manque
minimes ça commence à l'aimer quand on y
pense c'est qu'elles peuvent en dire
aussi c'est que la préménopause
ménopause
c'est à peu près la moitié d'espérance
de vie des femmes donc c'est un enjeu
majeur devrait concerner raconté qu y
est impressionnant mais pour qu'on se
laisse mais j'invite les gens à regarder
justement le travail de madame cloutier
ça s'appelle le tome énoncé présente et
surtout télé et ça fait vraiment un tas
board
on sort du mystère on sort de secret on
sort des tabous merci d'avoir participé
merci pour l'entrevue
merci beaucoup au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit